en plateau céline schmitt bonjour et
merci de répondre à france 24 cette
porte parole de l'ua na cher en france
le mhrc le haut commissariat des nations
unies pour les réfugiés il ya des
membres de l'ue mhr qui travaillent
actuellement en russie et en ukraine
vous disiez hier que le seuil des deux
millions de réfugiés sera franchi là
aujourd'hui ou demain deux millions de
personnes qui aient fui leur pays en 14
jours de guerre c'est inédit depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale oui
c'est un chiffre important et
effectivement c'est la plus grave crise
de déplacements en europe depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale le chiffre de
deux millions de réfugiés a
malheureusement été dépassé donc ce sont
maintenant à l'heure actuelle ce sont
deux millions 105 ans mais 155 mille
réfugiés qui ont traversé vers les pays
voisins principalement la pologne qui en
tout plus d'un million trois cent mille
réfugiés sont arrivés mais aussi vers la
moldavie vers la roumanie vers la
hongrie et vers la slovaquie donc c'est
ces pays là qu'ils ont gardé leurs
frontières ouvertes qui s'organisent les
gouvernements la société civile pour
accueillir les personnes leur apporter
une aide d'urgence
mais aussi une protection et nos équipes
au hcr sont aussi déployées on a
renforcé nos équipes sur place pour
soutenir cette réponse parce que c'est
la première urgence répondre aux besoins
prioritaires des gens qui arrivent après
avoir passé souvent de nombreux jours
sur la route avec très peu d'accès même
à de la nourriture ou ou très peu de
sommeil et puis aussi
il arrive très choqués et ont besoin
d'assistance vous dites donc que plus de
deux millions d'ukrainiens ont franchi
les frontières européennes en 14 jours
comment est-ce que la pologne la
roumanie
la moldavie notamment peut arriver à
accueillir dignement c'est ces personnes
en 14 jours
il ya une mobilisation sur place qu'il
faut reconnaître beaucoup de solidarité
une mobilisation de tous les acteurs
pour mettre en place
un accueil d'urgence un accueil
d'urgence avec de l'aide d'urgence quand
les personnes traversent la frontière
mais aussi un hébergement d'urgence mais
effectivement les défis sont énormes et
ces pays là ont besoin de soutien et ça
fait partie justement de nos appels un
soutien des autres états européens pour
faire face à la situation pour
accueillir les gens mais pour les
protéger aussi parce que au-delà des
besoins prioritaires il ya aussi des
alertes spécifiques qu'on a fait par
rapport notamment à la protection des
enfants parce que la majorité des
réfugiés qui arrivent sont des femmes
sont des enfants il faut apporter une
réponse immédiate en fait pour protéger
c'est sûr mais ce chiffre d'un million
d'enfants qui qui ont fui le traîne ça
peut être prêt de près de ce chiffre
n'est pas le chiffre exact mais
effectivement d'après les collègues qui
sont sur place la grande majorité des
personnes sont des femmes et des enfants
parce que les ukrainiens les hommes
doivent rester en ukraine parce que les
hommes restent donc il ya des
séparations aussi familial déchirante
que d'ailleurs mais mes collègues voient
parfois juste de l'autre côté de la
frontière
lorsque les femmes et les enfants
travers seul mais il ya aussi des
enfants seuls qui arrive est donc là
l'urgence est aussi de les accueillir
rapidement dans des endroits sûrs donc
on travaille à mettre en place aussi ce
qu'on appelle des points bleus c'est à
dire des lieux où les enfants peuvent
venir proche des lieux de traverser pour
être en sécurité parce qu'on sait que
des enfants seuls sur la route sont bien
évidemment extrêmement vulnérables à la
violence y compris aux risques
d'exploitation ou de traite donc ça fait
partie en fait des réponses d'urgence
aussi qui sont mises en place et où le
hcr aussi renforce en fait ses capacités
quels sont les droits de ces réfugiés il
ya une protection temporaire accordée
par l'union européenne ça veut dire
qu'ils ont accès aux soins ils peuvent
travailler oui tout à fait et c'est là
aussi une décision inédite depuis le
depuis l'adoption de cette directive sur
la protection temporaire suite à la
guerre dans les balkans donc en 2001
c'est la première fois que cette
directive a été activé et permet
effectivement aux personnes qui fuient
l'ukraine donc à la fois les ukrainiens
mais aussi les réfugiés par exemple
qu'il était réfugié en ukraine les
personnes qui avaient une résidence en
ukraine de bénéficier d'une protection
temporaire donc de ne pas avoir besoin
de faire une demande d'asile
individuelle mais de bénéficier de façon
collective en fait parce qu'ils fuient
l'ukraine de cette protection temporaire
et donc d'avoir accès au droit la
protection sociale bien sûr l'éducation
pour les enfants mais aussi selon les
règles des pays la possibilité de
travailler pour nous c'est quelque chose
de très important parce que ça permet
effectivement de rapidement protéger les
personnes comment ça se passe à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine d'abord à
combien de déplacer vous estimer le
nombre de déplacés donc en ukraine
depuis le début de la guerre on estime à
plus d'un million les personnes qui sont
déplacés en ukraine mais ce chiffre
pourrait être plus important parce que
il est difficile d'avoir des
informations exactes dans le contexte
actuel on a un bureau sur place on
attend on a des collègues qui
travaillent en ukraine depuis d'ailleurs
de nombreuses années on est présent
depuis 1994 et puis depuis 2014 on avait
des opérations humanitaires à l'est du
pays on a plus de 100 collègues qui sont
sur place qui sont restés sur place et
qui essaient de faire leur travail pour
apporter de l'aide humanitaire mais
aussi coordonner tout ce travail qu'on
appelle dans notre jargon le travail de
protection donc répertorié les incidents
les problèmes de protection des civils
et voir quels sont les acteurs à quels
endroits qui peuvent apporter une aide
c'est vrai que notre préoccupation et
l'accès humanitaire de pouvoir accorder
une aide on a déployé des stocks pour
pouvoir aider les personnes qui purgent
ans logistique c'est quoi concrètement
l'urgence alors l'urgence c'est de
pouvoir accéder de pouvoir apporter une
aide donc les médicaments de la
nourriture oui effectivement les besoins
sont énormes et presque dans tous les
domaines donc les vivres bien sûr
l'accès à la santé mais omis aussi
l'accès à l'eau l'accès à des
couvertures
l'axé aussi parfois à des par exemple
des bâches en plastique en fait pour se
mettre à l'abri donc parce que c'est
encore l'hiver et on le voit il neige
derrière derrière vous assure c'est sur
ces images vous estimez donc à pour
revenir sur ce chiffre de plus de deux
millions de réfugiés ça peut aller
jusqu'où ce n'est qu'un début le chiffre
augmente d'heure en heure de minute en
minute tous les jours
encore entre hier et aujourd'hui
c'est plus de 200 mille nouveaux
réfugiés qui sont arrivés en 24 heures
il y a encore des personnes sur les
routes il ya encore des personnes qui
attendent aux frontières pour entrer en
pologne pour rentrer en moldavie donc
effectivement le chiffon voir
humanitaire qui qui sont très difficiles
et qui sont visiblement très dangereux
merci en tout cas céline schmitt
porte-parole de l'ue et nasser en france
nous avoir apporté ces quelques
informations